The Avengers assembled once again
to show their support for Jeremy
Renner after his recent life-threatening accident.
Any day is a good day to show "Avengers"
star Jeremy Renner love, but right now,
in particular, he and his family
really need it. That's because,
on Monday, January 2nd, Renner suffered
injuries related to a snowplow accident,
sending him to the hospital in critical
condition and requiring two surgeries.
Fortunately, the surgeries
appear to have gone well,
with his condition now described as
"critical but stable." On Tuesday,
January 3rd, Renner made an Instagram post
showing himself in his hospital bed, writing,
"Oh, he's flatlining. Call it. Time?"
"No, no, no, I'm gonna live forever.
I'm gonna be made of plastic!"
The accident occurred after Renner attempted to
use his snowplow to clear a path for a family
member's trapped vehicle. He stepped outside
the vehicle to talk to the family member,
at which point the snowplow started to
move on its own. Renner tried to jump
into the vehicle to stop it but instead was
run over, causing multiple serious injuries.
The beloved actor's Instagram has
over 5 million likes and over 200,000
comments, most of which are expressing
their love for Renner and wishing him
a quick recovery. However, it's not just
common fans expressing their best wishes.
Among the hundreds of thousands of
comments wishing Jeremy Renner well
were those who have starred alongside
him in the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
Renner plays Clint Barton, also known as Hawkeye.
Chris Hemsworth, who plays
Thor in the MCU commented,
Hemsworth is not the only Chris from
the MCU sending his love to the actor.
Chris Pratt, who plays Peter
Quill, also known as Star-Lord,
in the "Guardians of the Galaxy" and "Avengers"
films, commented on Renner's post, writing,
But there was still one more Chris to send some
love Renner's way. Chris Evans, who plays Steve
Rogers in the "Captain America" and "Avengers"
films, also had kind words. Evans wrote,
Beyond actors named Chris, Paul Bettany,
who plays Vision in "WandaVision"
and the "Avengers" films, wrote,
Josh Brolin, who plays the
villainous Thanos, wrote,
Alaqua Cox, who plays Echo, in "Hawkeye" and
the upcoming Disney+ series "Echo," also took
to Instagram to send Renner her love,
simply commenting with two heart emojis.
Finally, Mark Ruffalo, who plays Bruce Banner and
his alter ego the Hulk wrote
on his own Instagram account,
It's not only Jeremy Renner's fellow actors
from the MCU who are sending him their love,
however. Many of the various directors of
the MCU's films have also taken to the star's
comment section to show him they're thinking of
him and wishing him the best in his recovery.
Taika Waititi, director of
"Thor: Ragnarök" and "Thor:
Love and Thunder," commented on Renner's
post, writing, "My brother I love you."
Anthony and Joe Russo, directors of several of the
biggest films in the MCU franchise
also left a kind comment, writing,
Last but not least, James Gunn, director
of the "Guardians of the Galaxy" films,
posted a single heart and an emoji of hands being
raised to show Renner his love and well wishes.
As terrible of a situation
the beloved actor is in,
he at least won't want for kind messages
from his fans and co-workers alike.